the Sunnah is the wife has the right to
live separately from her husband's
family and if the husband is not willing
to provide that then he needs to find
someone that is willing to fit in that
bracket but for me personally it's
almost like you know you've got eyes on
you every mistake you know every cooking
if you know how many times a day
everything you you've just got like a
spotlight on you they find it hard to be
away from their parents and sometimes I
ask myself do I have this negative like
mummy's boy perception about this
because of my own upbringing and because
of
this lack of culture and how distant
family are maybe it's great that they
have this this love and attachment you
know you don't really know you know you
don't know each other too well so you're
getting to know him he's getting to know
you and I want the freedom to just walk
around without my hijab exactly because
my brother-in-laws I have to you know be
modest from them because like from my
culture I'm Kurdish Turkey
um we don't to us we expected you get
married move out you get your own place
yeah I find it a little bit strange the
fact that nudie Weds bro come on Rob
you're living with your in-laws you want
to be having private moments with my
wife and worried about whoever other
indoors anyone else present in the house
he's living with your family the same
for him he has to walk on eggshells he
has to cover his modesty around your
sisters they've lived with their in-laws
it has really caused a lot of problems
from day one and they do not have that
sense of Dean and taking on that
daughter-in-law as their own daughter
unfortunately I feel like this was kind
of a history class and sort of the what
the actual topic is should newlyweds
live with their in-laws that's what
we're talking about we're not talking
about culture Pakistan India Bangladesh
that is so irrelevant but that's not the
point of the topic
no
don't miss this amazing opportunity from
Nature's blends to get your finest
premium black seed oil and shilajit to
get that energy levels back up check
them out now
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are winning inshallah
welcome to another episode of The Bitter
truth inshallah
um it's been a mad day anyways
um before I start I want to praise Allah
the most merciful the most trust or
Praises glory and gratitude belong to
him and also I want to thank the people
Abdul Kareem my brother anas
um and many other team members who have
made this happen and I want to thank the
co-producer which is my wife who helps
me decide these topics as we have heated
debates at home anyways so moving
swiftly on uh Butters Butters buzzers
[Laughter]
so the buses if if you disagree with
someone so let's say this is the speaker
and you disagree you press it you have
one and a half minutes no one can
disturb you yeah okay so you have a
chance only once to press it
um yeah and that's it let's get straight
into it this is a phenomena that happens
in the Asian Community
um you are Pakistani yourself
it's a big problem in your subcontinent
anyways should new new Brides
live with in-laws now I hear these
issues a lot
sometimes this is message and say you
know what brother you know my
mother-in-law father-in-law is treat me
like this or streaming like that I want
to know myself please how many uh Asians
here like one two Pakistani
anyways Pakistani
oh Afghani okay interesting okay no
problem so can you please tell us yeah
because I really want to know because
like for my culture Kurdish Turkey
um we don't to us we expected you get
married move out you get your own place
yeah I find it a little bit strange the
fact that Newly Weds bro come on Rob
you're living with your in-laws so I'm
gonna open the discussion inshallah do
you think that is correct let's start
with the sisters and before they maybe
introduce yourself we've got a new
sister assistant
yeah okay so come in uh please tell us a
bit about yourself inshallah
I am currently a student athlete and I
just create content part-time bless you
my dear sister
um is becoming a regular and she's with
her husband
um bless them preserves their marriage
inshallah Mustafa how long you guys be
married so uh coming up to three and a
half years now yeah coming up to three
and a half years now I preserve you guys
inshallah
children and alhamdulillah
bless you this is what we want to see
more marriages stable marriages handling
I'll preserve you guys so that you're
here with your dear wife yes uh sister
and maybe you can tell a bit about
yourself
yeah
um so my name is I'm currently studying
a Bachelor's of Science degree of
psychology
um as my husband mentioned we've got two
kids under two alhamdulillah I also
teach part-time and the Arabic language
Quran and Civic studies to children ages
um 7 to 18.
um and I also do a weekly class on Zoom
at Alberta Institute where I mentor and
discuss various topics surrounding
mental health from an Islamic and
secular perspective
about yourself
um so my name is
I'm 35 divorced
I have a daughter who's four years old
alhamdulillah
um I work in the corporate world so I
work in compliance and
alhamdulillah you know it's a
it's not easy juggling motherhood and
full-time work but alhamdulillah you
know and I'm just here to share my views
on
what it's like both sides yes
she speaks a lot of facts truths we
actually invited her specifically but
she actually applied beforehand uh may
Allah bless her
um she was an ex-feminist
yes yes but no no they actually invited
us but uh yeah but the thing is it's
interesting because may Allah bless you
we need more sisters like you with your
mentality to exist which we're going to
come out come to later but um
just a little bit about yourself
Islam is this close enough to the mic
I'm a river to Islam I've been a Muslim
for a little over 12 years
um I do counseling through a class
counseling which I've been doing for
about
five years now alhamdulillah
um I also work in the construction
industry
I design clothes and a newly
deal with CMOS
may God bless you okay so let's start
with the topic inshallah like I said
which is should do you guys agree that
Brides should live new brights Brighton
should live with in-laws what do you
mean um live with in-laws do you mean
like I'm so sorry so sorry I forgot to
your husband
forgive me forgive me forgive me
sorry
this is
I'm here with my wife uh I don't know we
got married three and a half years ago
we have two daughters under two and
currently I work as an auditor
um in one of the big four firms
um specializing in financial services
um and in my free time I help you know
mentor
uh graduates land their first role
um in Professional Services and I also
help you know in my personal time with
friends who are looking to get married
and also who are going through issues
um in their marriage as well
you're saying so no I was just gonna
wait to clarify the question a bit what
do you mean live with them do you mean
like in the same house where you share
all the common spaces or like on two
different floors within the same house
tell me tell me your perspective on both
so let's talk about one where it's
you're sharing everything and one you
have your some sort of on Space okay so
I just want to start by saying that
obviously not this like this like
there's no like one size fit all
situation for marriages like every
marriage and every laws of different and
you're understanding that develops with
them develops over time so it could be
quite detrimental at the beginning
especially when you're new to that
family you don't know their values they
don't know how they function around the
house
um so over time obviously if you develop
the understanding with them then you you
could you and your husband come to terms
that okay you know if need be we can
live with them or take care of them
um but I think it's also a difference
when they come live with you versus when
you go live with them because when they
come and living with you they're living
under your terms and you don't lose your
Independence because they kind of fit in
your lifestyle versus what are you gonna
live with them it's like you're
adjusting your life you know and certain
Dynamics
um to cater to their lifestyle
and then I think
um another thing is that there's always
going to be that judgment from them
unfortunately whether it's direct or
indirect
um because the new people and once again
you don't really know about each other
do you so
um yeah so I think that these are some
things to take into consideration if you
consider moving because obviously it
dependence as well as you said that yeah
just just something else I want to say I
think it's really important to consider
why you're actually living with in-laws
so some people that have like a in the
Asian Community they have a joint family
system so growing up it's just expected
that once they get married their wife is
going to come and live in the same
household as them but some people some
of my friends what they do is they they
live within like that you know they
their wife comes to live in their
household
um but only to the extent where they're
able to save up in order to move out and
you know either rent or buy their own
property so I think it's really
important to be clear as as to why um
you're living with in-laws it might not
be that it's for the you know for the
foreseeable future uh it could be for
the short term instead of the long term
um so yeah that's a I think the things
in the Asian culture it's not short-term
it's quite yeah so it's quite a long
term so this is something that's
important to clarify the thing so I mean
sister would you I mean if you got newly
married would you feel comfortable
living with your in-laws or would you
want like your own space with your
husband so firstly when you get married
to someone you're experiencing something
new with them it's supposed to be
something blessed sacred and naturally
speaking you would want to have that
private intimate moment with your
husband or your wife personally for me
from the get-go I will tell my to be
husband I want to live us to separate
from your family is that what you want
yes or no if he says no Then
alhamdulillah have a good day you go
find a wife that would be willing to
live with your family but for me
personally
I'm Bengali and I and I sit in that
culture where most newlyweds live with
their in-laws I don't agree it's not
about culture we're talking about Islam
we're talking about the Hadith we're
talking about the Sunnah the Sunnah is
the wife has the right to live
separately from her husband's family and
if the husband is not willing to provide
they'll all you know work with that then
he needs to find someone that is willing
to fit in that bracket but for me
personally
you know why try to fix something that's
not broken it's just black and white yes
or no I feel like over complicating the
question is just unnecessary so that's
just where I stand on that interesting
straight to the point the other business
system has an interesting perspective
she's straight to the point of messing
around that you know yes like I mean is
there anything from the Quran to say
that she has to live with the parents I
don't think so from what I know
um sister SWAT um look from a Somali
background
um how is it in your culture for example
if you was asked to stay with your
in-laws how is it with the Somali
culture
and they can't get rid of you quick
enough
they want you out ASAP Rocky but um
um so when I got married
um it was under the so my ex and I we
had the conversation and I said that I
wanted to have my own space the option
was there to move in with my in-laws but
I I wouldn't because look when you're
new you're starting to get to know each
other and you don't want to do that in a
room full of people exactly exactly it's
a family who would and I'm not saying
this is what my you know ex family it
did but well
my ex's family what they did but uh it
it's almost like you know you've got
eyes on you every mistake you know every
cooking you know if you know how many
times a day you'll cook everything
you've just got like a spotlight on you
whereas if you've got your own space you
can learn it get to know each other and
learn more about each other and you can
make your mistakes and have your private
arguments because in the beginning
that's when you have a lot of the
clashes you know you don't really know
you know you don't know each other too
well so you're getting to know him he's
getting to know you and I want the
freedom to just walk around without my
hijab exactly because my brother-in-laws
I have to you know be modest from them
and of course my father and I won't have
to but you know using the toilet when
I'm showering I have to make sure
there's nobody around so at least having
that space of mine for me and my husband
to truly get to know each other and I
think that would give you the best foot
forward in your marriage could I just
also add to what the sister has said I
totally agree with everything you said
and I also to mention that
just because I am opposed to living with
my husband's family that doesn't that
doesn't mean I'm not also opposed to you
know maybe staying a night over spending
time with this family building that
connection of course I have no problem
with doing that and what you said about
walking around without the hijab born
you know being able to shower without
thinking that I lock the door is there
anyone outside oh no I've got my towel I
can't go get out I can't like these
little small small things will catch up
to you in the long term and that's when
those clashes will come with you and
your husband when the honeymoon phase is
over your husband is going to be like
why are you acting like this it's not
the woman I married yeah where's my
right where's my privacy where's my when
you're at his family exactly you're
gonna kind of keep a lot in yeah my God
is up my God is up because I don't want
you you're not going to be I don't want
it yourself yeah I don't want to give
the wrong impression to the Sami at the
end of the day I care about him and his
family yeah and I want to be mindful as
well just to say
um on the other side if he's living with
your family the same for him he has to
walk on eggshells he has to cover his
modesty around your sisters and he's not
comfortable so again it's both
you know in-laws from her side or his
side it's I feel and I think is
detrimental to newlyweds yeah we have a
topic called should
um in-laws get involved in marital
disputes in this very instance they are
in it I mean you can't get away with it
you know and I always say that keep keep
it away like arguments away from your
in-laws because at the end of the day
it's going to be toxic we discusses on
one of the episode we released because
if you have an argument and then you go
and tell like I make a principle like me
and my wife my mom I love like me and my
wife will have arguments it's normal by
the way guys hello yes marriage is
normal you have fights arguments don't
worry if you didn't you should be
worried if you don't argue yeah okay
that's IG that's weird yeah yeah so
these arguments happen and my mom will
always come to me tell me what happened
tell me no it's not looking you don't
need to know why okay imagine a
conversation okay Mom this happened she
might have a resentment towards my wife
she will and the vice versa if my wife
went and said he did this and this and
this yeah okay and we make up and when
we make up you guys got the the parents
are going to be the one that's going to
be bad because don't get involved so
it's better they're not even but in this
very instance
as well that I mean what would you guys
say because at the end of the day now
they're involved bro do you not think
it's detrimental to the marriage and I
know there are situations I know there
are situations where there's exceptions
so if the husband for example his mom
has nowhere to go yeah these are
exceptions or vice versa she has a
father and if she has married there's no
one to look after him 100 of course
we're not talking about these instances
where these things can happen but do not
believe zishan will reveal that this is
detrimental to the marriage that
everything is going on in front of their
very eyes
well first of all I think that
whether the couple are living amongst
in-laws or not
I think it very much if if it's in a man
or a woman's character to expose the
shortcomings of their spouse
regardless of if the in-laws are living
with them or not they will come to know
about it and sometimes
if the in-laws aren't present in the
home to see the reality of what's taking
place in the home and one layer whether
it be the Sun
or whether it be the daughter
is going to our parents and complain to
those who are outside of the home so
let's say for example a sisters moved in
with her husband
and her parents are obviously at their
home and she calls complaining about
um my husband did this my husband did
that if they're not present in the home
and seeing what's taking place on a
daily basis then they can have a very
distorted understanding of the reality
of what's taking place so sometimes it
can actually be good for the parents to
be present in the home because they see
the character and the behavior of the
wife and they also see that
character and behavior of the husband
so there can be benefits when there are
family disputes or dispute between
husband and wife and there are wise
in-laws present in the home to actually
deal with it in a good manner I think
the problem arises
when you have
biased in-laws unjust in-laws unwise
in-laws who will witness their own child
oppressing their spouse but because it's
their child they'll defend them
and I've I'm familiar with a situation
where
this was actually causing severe
problems in the marriage and when I say
this I'm referring to
one of the spouses behaving in in a not
so good manner to
to the other spouse
let me be a little bit clearer
the sun is not behaving well to the
his wife but the wife lives with
uh my friend-in-law and her husband but
the mother
the mother-in-law is defending her son
even when he's clearly in the wrong
and this causes friction because not
only does it not hold the sun
accountable but it also makes the
daughter-in-law feel
oppressed unloved
she has to be around these people every
single day
and it was to such an extent that I
actually had a conversation with the
brother and he said that this is a
genuine problem he actually acknowledged
the fact that his mother's Behavior was
a problem in their marriage it would
have been better if she actually held
him accountable
you know so it really depends on the
circumstances there's so many nuances
and so many different Avenues but when
it comes to the nature of marriage
there's so many you really need an
in-depth understanding of what's
actually taking place but um of course
if you're having issues and the in-laws
are in the home it's very hard to avoid
of course they're going to hear shouting
they're going to hear screaming they're
going to seize people's faces that are
happy or upset so it's difficult to
avoid but again it all depends on the
in-laws
are we talking in in regards to
generally or with regards to arguments
but generally to live with the in-laws
okay well obviously as a river it's not
our custom
it's not our custom
um my preference is to have privacy
my preference is to be able to walk
around as freely as I want
I don't want to I don't want to be
having private moments with my wife and
worried about my my
whoever are for indoors anyone else
present in the house
that's very uncomfortable and just
something I can never really wrap my
head around sometimes if I pluck up the
courage I might ask some of my Asian
companions how they deal with that
um
because I really can't understand it but
at the same time as well
I also think that there's a lot of
barricade
yeah I I know I know people who have
very good relationships with their
in-laws
their in-laws love them they love their
and of course
they will take time perhaps book a hotel
perhaps go away for a period of time
and then come back so if they need
moments of privacy if they have the
means they have the provision then they
can always get time away from their
in-laws of course
practically you're not every week on a
book somewhere and and go away this is
this isn't this isn't real life
but um
yeah I'm familiar with many instances
where where being living with the
in-laws is is an enjoyable experience
for both
very interesting perspective what do you
have to say uh first of all masha'allah
a view that's not discussed as much
today and I like the way you kind of
presented that because it depends on the
in-laws depends on does the spouses
themselves generally speaking however I
think with the olama that I've kind of
come across they actually recommend
um use sting and living separately to
your in-laws
um reason being because I mean if you
look at the nature of the way your
marriage is it's it's two people I well
generally they're they're young
generally and they're unfamiliar with a
lot of things they're going to be making
mistakes and unfortunately and sadly
when other people are involved now when
the husband and the wife they reconcile
now you have to reconcile with the other
people they're gonna be angry then you
have to deal with that aspect as well so
in one argument instead of two people
there's like three four people and
unfortunately some people they remember
certain things and
over time Things become
poison starts building up and resentment
starts building up and generally
speaking this this has happened and
that's why the the Imam the local Imam
he says as well if you want to have that
loving relationship with your son uh
send him away like let him have his own
place that way that absence makes the
heart grow fonder but if you're there in
each other's face all the time and you
know this conflict of understanding and
stuff like that it's actually
unnecessarily messy now the thing is you
said Asian community
yeah let me say that again the Asian
Community yeah
uh it seems like you do
so let's let's have a bit of a history
lesson here yeah yeah ready for the
history lesson I'm ready yeah so the
Asian community comprises of India
Pakistan and Bangladesh yeah yeah that's
what that's what I was talking about
thank you yeah so they used to live in
one place called Hindustan yeah it was
it was actually one place India today uh
yeah
not the India today it's India Pakistan
and Bangladesh yeah
you following me so far
[Laughter]
so so at that time the thing is we we
have even in terms of when we get
married we have a lot of kind of Indian
Customs that have seeped in yeah and
they have been kind of influential in
certain things so that's that's one
aspect the other thing Ali is that
we were colonized by the British for
about 200 years yeah whilst we were very
economically well off however during The
british's Reign we actually were not it
was incredibly difficult so let's just
say you had a plot of land and in that
plot of land you would you know get all
your relatives kind of in there it
wouldn't be feasible it wouldn't be
feasible for you to buy loads of land
and and kind of spread everything so
back in the days when I would go to
Pakistan I would actually see that yes
in one house you have you know the
people that got married but now in The
Villages I'm seeing now that people are
becoming more financially okay they are
now like the sister said they are now
actually creating stories now so on the
one one level you've got the parents on
the other level you've got the first
family that's why that question was
actually a very good question because
when you say that this is very
prevalent amongst the Asians are you
talking about now are you talking about
in the past or are you talking about
some delusion that you've concocted in
your head
yeah no absolutely I'm waiting for this
because a lot of you guys have been
really really calm and very I want to
talk about the reality because I deal
with hundreds of families across the
globe and from different backgrounds and
it does stem from the South Asian
background where they are a lot of
problems when they do live with their
in-laws and they are very unfairly
unjust to the daughter-in-laws in
particular and most most of the time it
is the the women that moves in with the
in-laws so I've had first capacity do
they come to you like counselor or yes
okay as a counselor yes so coaching yeah
so it makes sense that people with
issues will go to a counselor and I also
get recommendation from the scholars
because they've had divorces and they've
had issues they go to the scholar they
can't sort it out and then the scholar
comes to me it to sort of say go and
steal with you know see fahima for the
actual uh reconciliation or the issues
that you know has been dissolved in the
marriage and how to go afterwards and
most of it comes from the fact that if
they've lived with their in-laws it has
really caused a lot of problems from day
one and they do not have that sense of
Deen and taking on that daughter-in-law
as their own daughter unfortunately in
Muslim homes because it is more cultural
than it is in those sort of particular
backgrounds yeah which I have first-hand
experience of listening to that it's
more about the culture than it is the
religion yeah so so like I said I mean I
already talked about that and it is in
the UK in the western world as well not
just from The Villages that you're
talking about right it's happening
currently right so now the question
arises that how is it happening in the
UK
uh so the people that have actually come
and have migrated
the people that have migrated they've
migrated because generally speaking they
have actually not been financially well
off there so it's these same individuals
with the same practices that have now
migrated that have come here just
because you think it's Financial I think
it's more no no no it's the
statistically speaking the people that
have migrated to the UK that are from
India Pakistan Bangladesh are those that
were actually not well off over there
they've come here for a better life
they're not better life when they're
still living the old life yeah but
that's besides the point the point is
that it's disadvantaged people that have
come and over there when they were
disadvantaged this culture was prevalent
so they've somehow imported that culture
hair and they are doing that and slowly
slowly they are now becoming aware that
it's actually not really needed yeah
it's actually counterproductive but to
deny or to say that oh it's it's there's
no real background there is a background
and the background comes from people at
that time time that it was actually not
feasible for them to be buying loads of
plots plots of land and separating and
scattering the family now the way things
are happening over there and I've seen
it myself it is the fact that they are
now doing that because they are able to
it's more easier to buy land it's more
easier to build and that's why the the
kind of perceptions and Views are now
changing I don't know where it's
changing because a lot of the time again
it's not just about the finance they
just expect their sons to be living in
the house with them and bring the
daughter-in-law in there it's changing I
mean I I go there and I'm I'm kind of
well acquainted with the people with the
people that are there as well no no you
don't have to stop straight away yeah
finish the sentence yeah yeah so I lost
my train of thought
you said you went to Pakistan and you've
seen it yeah yeah so so you're saying
where I mean from from the people that
are there from observing it myself from
going to Villages and seeing people kind
of separating their families because it
actually doesn't work like when there's
an imperative and you're realizing that
it actually you know that you can't move
out it's not actually financially
possible you've been colonized so you
have to kind of make do then you do it's
like in war and you're you're given
Russian food however after War finishes
then it's not practical to carry that
rationing mentality on when when you can
change that behavior so it's the same
case now when people are now coming and
when people are seeing that like you
said cases are coming to you and that's
why it's not working out why because
that moment or that time that we were
colonized that you know we had an
imperative to kind of survive in that
time it's no longer needed now and
that's why there has become a generation
still consistently it does but the
youngsters like their sister has said as
well they've made it clear in their
expectations that they that they don't
yeah they don't want to do that okay
let's go to the next can I just say
um you've got one and a half minutes can
I just say I feel like we're kind of
going away from the actual of this
conversation I feel like this was kind
of a history class instead of the what
the actual topic is should newlyweds
live with their in-laws that's what
we're talking about we're not talking
about culture Pakistan India Bangladesh
that is so irrelevant but that's not the
point of the topic
that's not the point I do we were in a
room full of different cultures and
different backgrounds but the point
stands is that should newlywed Weds live
in their in-laws personally no you may
think differently because of your
culture and the way you were raised and
the history and so on and so forth but I
feel like what sister over here said
about you know how mothers treat their
sons and what their expectations have
yes that's very prevalent but the
question is should newly Wesley with
their in-laws that's it that's why I
interrupted just so we can like mediate
the conversation back to what the topic
is you've got 30 seconds
yes so so the reason I brought up the
Asian point was because you
categorically said Asians and it was
repeated like two three times it's not
like that there does need to be a
historical latitude because if you're
asking it's present in the Asian
Community why then you have to give a
reason and if the reason historical then
you need to provide a historical thing
and a historical narrative and before
the historical narrative I gave a
categorical answer about what Scholars
recommend and what my opinion is
regarding the matter so both things were
covered what what washers name sisters
mentioned
at the beginning
um was really and truly it probably one
of the most important points and it's
about having a very transparent
clear dialogue in the beginning
there's there's a brother that I train
with at grappling
and I see his lifestyle he travels a lot
um
and I assumed that he wasn't married
because of this
and he said I'm married bro I've been
married for two years and I was like wow
bro you're always you know here there
going to Manchester to watch this
calisthenics competition and it's that
in the oven and he said bro before I got
married I had a clear conversation with
my wife that this is how I want to live
and this is how I want things to be
and if she agreed with it finding if she
didn't no problem if you have the
communication early
and you let your spouse know I'm not
interested in marrying you if you if you
don't have a place for us by yourself
then this will save a lot of problems
but I've had a number of sessions with
clients where
they're having issues in in the home due
to their in-laws
and I think that we would all probably
agree
that in most cases living with in-laws
is much more complicated and problematic
than living with just you and your
spouse there's a lot more juggling
a lot more plates to juggle or spin as
they say so
you know that that's a reality that we
can't escape but if you're transparent
and you're clear from the beginning and
that can that can go in two different
ways I'll explain if you say what sister
naznin says for it we'll say for example
and made it clear from the beginning she
will save herself hassle because she'll
be marrying someone who's already got a
place she'll be making sure that that
that's known however there are sisters
who agree to living with their
in Los
and then after some time
there are some trials some tests and now
they're forcing their husband and
they're putting conditions on their
husband which they islamically have
but they're putting pressure on him to
now be able to provide a place
now
the brother was mentioning about back
home
and about means the cost of living in
this country and particularly in this
city has gone through the roof
so it's very difficult for brothers I
don't know if you guys have seen what
the rent Market is like but it's crazy
so for some brothers
it's actually going to damage their
finances greatly to go and rent
somewhere
and were they to live with the in-laws
that the husband and wife can
potentially have a much better quality
of life
for us depending but yeah yeah of course
depending on the circumstances around
around the home but they'll have more
disposable income to be able to perhaps
travel more or to be able to go out
morning and enjoy things with each other
so you know there's there's multiple you
know ways of
um if the in-laws don't interfere I've
I've heard of stories where the the the
wife would be like I would go work earn
extra and let's get on please exactly
and I've seen this happen
literally she was like I would
contribute let's bounce yeah I've seen
that so I don't know is it I don't know
if there's any more things the brother
made an excellent point yeah just
quickly finish one one thing quickly
because I need I need to make this point
but I actually lost track slightly if a
sister does agree with her husband or
doesn't make any issue with living with
in-laws then I really do feel that it's
almost to an extent upon her to be
patient with the situation she should
she should certainly Express herself and
say that listen look I thought I'd be
able to
it's actually difficult like I think
that we need to get our own place and
then be patient with that transition and
be patient with because you have to
remember the husband probably wants to
live by by himself with his wife anyway
do you understand but then he's
I've noticed that in the Asian community
there's a lot of Mommy's ways to be
honest with you really really
interesting
I don't want to be offensive I try to
slow it down but I just said let me just
say it because I'll take too long
you know um they find it hard to be away
from their parents and sometimes I ask
myself do I have this negative like
mummy Square perception about this
because of my own upbringing and because
of
this lack of culture and how distant
family are maybe it's created that they
have this this love and attachment or
maybe it goes a little bit a little bit
too far but the husband in most
instances you probably really wants to
be alone with his wife but then he's
also going to have pressure from his
parents about leaving them and then
there's the Islamic perspective on
taking care of your parents and being
dutiful to your parents and things of
that nature so there's a lot of pressure
on the husband's side that the wife
needs to empathize with and have
patience with when it comes to this I
think that's interesting man you know
it's a fine balance because at the end
of the day I think it's a beautiful
thing but they have what you guys have
in your culture which is that you know
bond with the family and I think
everyone has it uh to that level and I
suppose there's extremes of mummies boys
Etc how about this thing about mummies
boys though I don't I don't think
no no no it's it's actually not it's
actually not mommy's boys it's the way
obedience is seen in the Asian culture
and if a person is kind of moving out is
that seen as being disrespectful or this
or that it's not oh the person can't
survive without the mom or this or that
no it's actually that okay if I move
will I be called a bad son and how will
it be seen yeah it's that stigma and
stuff like that and again it's it's
stuff that we're shirking off because it
is affecting uh marital relationships
and that's that's actually undeniable
why because of the nature because of the
way things have become now back in the
days you know a village was a village
now the whole world has become a global
village even in the Villages you're
seeing programs and shows and stuff like
that so people are consuming the same
content it's actually very difficult for
you to consume that content and still be
okay with living a traditional life so
we have to kind of understand that the
times that we're in now you know and the
content that we're consuming is actually
very difficult for us to kind of
maintain that traditional old-school
form of living but the brother did say
something fantastic which is that if you
are to kind of meet in the middle and be
balanced balanced you can say that okay
I'm not financially strong but if we
stay with the in-laws for a short period
of time that we can step you know stand
on our feet and then we can do that
there does need to be some some
understanding some people go too much on
one extreme and say no totally not some
people say no no we will and we'll you
know it'll be right the rooms will be
next to each other and this and that
there needs to be space and like the
people were saying to to to kind of walk
around freely you know not worry about
you know I have to cover myself I mean
living with a brother-in-law is
ridiculous to be honest I think that's
that's that's good
and stuff like that I mean you're
supposed to you should want to see your
wife you know and and not in a certain
way good not only that but the process
said the the brother the the
brother-in-law is like death
and and most most kind of Haram
relationships take place with the people
that kind of frequent the home and stuff
like that
your wife your wife
you've got one and a half minutes we're
gonna wrap up and shall I move to our
next shopping very soon so yeah you've
got one half minute now yeah I was gonna
say that I agree with Brothers ishan um
about everything he said but um because
I have experienced myself first time
living with my brother-in-law and
sister-in-law once again I think it's
all about communication and management
and it's definitely different to when
you're living with the parity laws
because that the Elder than you they
have you know that that respect is like
expected from you but if you live with
somebody sister Lord you have that
communication and you can make your work
work out for like a short term
especially I think it's not that much of
an issue to be honest and also I was
going to say just interlinking with this
topic about in-laws I think the sun has
a very integral part in you know that
communication that that understanding
that happens
um when you marry a girl obviously she
has no idea about your family so you're
the one who's responsible to teach her
about your family tell her what your mom
likes tell her what your dad likes tell
her what they expect of you
um as a couple or what they expect
yes I think that that becomes an issue
also I think another thing is that
before sons are married they're very
close to their parents and then all of a
sudden they get married and then they're
just and the parents think oh wait a
minute especially not you know Asian
Community cultures it's because of her
because she polluted uh yeah she
brainwashed her and that's not fair and
that's the subject that assumption is
the mother of all it listens to Vision
you know it's not it's not a good trait
so we should be very very important
seven seconds yeah come unless you
review your wife
seven seconds
you've got seven seconds
and the question is should newlyweds
live with their in-laws my personal
answer is I I really know especially for
the short term no did you say no okay
yeah I think no because it's really
important especially in that newly
married phase where you're literally
just getting to know each other
um it's really important to be alone
together in that time because in my in
my personal experience you know talking
to friends who've gone through the same
thing the main issue comes with
expectations and judgments from the
parents-in-laws who have expectations of
what they expect from the wife who's
just coming to the family and that's
where the real issue comes in
um you as a newlywed couple have you
you're sort of still figuring figuring
out your expectations of what you want
from your husband and your wife and then
there's a third party that comes along
and says you know your wife should
should be doing this or you should be
doing this as a husband or you shouldn't
let your wife do this or do that and
that was a huge issue because now you're
doubting yourself and thinking you know
is marketing this wrong or you know
what's going on and when you have that
inference from outside that's where I've
I've seen the most questions I agree
guys I want to wrap you up inshallah and
I think you know what's important as
well like we mentioned some key factors
is that there is no evidence from the
Quran Sunnah to stipulate on the wife
that she has to live within usually
clear and initial
I'm going to finish this and then come
to the the bitter truth that matters is
that in real as men we will call that
out we're not here to you know
towards each other that maybe if the the
the husband has got a father or a mother
or vice versa there should be some kind
of Mercy it shouldn't be cut throat like
and this is one of the things that we
see and the prophet sallam said may his
face be rubbed in dirt may his face be
rubbed in dirt and he repeated said may
his face be rubbed in dirt for the one
whose parents reach old age and they
abundant them and then imagine the wife
or the husband asking the other one to I
don't care I don't want to know I don't
think anyone's that merciles I don't
think anyone's saying that here we're
just saying in general it can be
detrimental but we should understand
each other have mercy and imagine if
that was your family imagine your
husband saying to you no your dad I
don't care so imagine that is what
inshallah we'll finish off with zeeshan
last one yeah sometimes that Arab the
Arab and the Asian culture seems very
synonymous with their religion but it's
actually not necessarily
um religion per se and this could be
maybe because Asians were the first kind
of of spread religion here in the UK and
they they get a bad rep but the thing is
that regardless of whatever culture
you're from if you lack religion then
that's going to be a problem and
whatever culture you are whatever
background we need religion for
grounding and you know you can be of a
certain culture as long as you've got
religion there as well to tame that
culture then you're going to be fine
however you can be of a certain culture
but if the religion is less and you
don't fear a lot then that's going to be
a problem and we do see cases in which
and I hope we did get that across but in
case we didn't some people are living in
oppressive relationships they are
literally being oppressed and they are I
would even say in some regards you know
borderline abusive relationships as well
um because you know somebody is
vulnerable they've gone there and maybe
they might not be able to communicate
properly and they're being dominated by
multiple family members so in that
regard like sister fahima said there's
help if you are in that you know situ
situation please do reach out and do
kind of consult your local Imam you can
get his number from you know just
nowadays you can just Google the Masjid
and then the numbers will come up you
can speak to somebody but speak to
somebody that can kind of help you and
support you not somebody that's just
going to tell you oh do this you cut
this or finish this or do that somebody
that's going to give you practical
Solutions like the imam's sensor and
clientele to sister as well bless you
guys inshallah our honorable sisters and
brothers uh don't forget our response on
Nature's Blends inshallah black seed oil
capsule version and Charlotte brothers
and sisters makes the most out of it
inshallah may Allah bless them because
they hope this podcast happen takes a
lot of effort time even money uh
blessing for sponsoring this until next
time from the bitty trip show
assalamualaikum